well good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we're trying to find
things to be happy about and actually if
you look hard enough there are a lot of
them
one of the best things about say a
supreme court confirmation hearing is
that you get to see the u.s senate in
action and this is new if you're like
most people you know the senate has 100
members or two from every state and you
know they're somehow important they're
in the constitution so they wear dark
suits and red ties to work they talk
about laws every summer they fly to
foreign countries and act like their
president some of them you me you may
even know by name the famous ones like
chuck schumer and mitch mcconnell
obviously the publicity addicts like
lindsey graham and of course the ones
you see on your own ballot every six
years so that's what you know
but do you really know these people
who are they really what are they like
unless you happen to live next door to
one or you watch an inordinate amount of
c-span it's hard to know what they're
like and that's why confirmation
hearings are so great
you get to see us senators in their
natural habitat
turns out there are confirmation
hearings underway right now you may have
heard about them for a biden appointee
called cantangie jackson now jackson is
a world-renowned legal genius who for
reasons that are still not clear cannot
determine what a woman is we told you
about her last night
but so far the star of these hearings
has not been contangi jackson it's been
a junior senator from new jersey called
corey booker
now like contangi jackson cory booker is
also a world famous legal scholar hence
his seat on the judiciary committee
booker attended not only stanford and
yale law school but then went all the
way to oxford university in england on
the coveted rhodes scholarship he has
quite a resume if academic credentials
still had any connection to ability or
achievement cory booker would be a very
impressive person but in his case we're
going to have to grade on a curve
because cory booker has come a long way
cory booker is from a world you have
never been to he's from a hard
unforgiving world of crime decay and raw
urban authenticity cory booker is from
the streets of newark
he once described his world in an
interview quote i still remember my
first month on the street he said i
walked up to this charismatic black guy
my age called t-bone who's one of the
drug lords i said yo man what's up
and he leaped up in front of me looked
me right in the eye and said
who the blank do you think you are if
you ever so much as look at me again i'm
gonna put a cap in your ass
now t-bone as you probably concluded was
one of newark's most notorious drug
lords as joe biden might have said he
was a bad dude but cory booker is a bad
dude too in his own way and the two
became close the rhodes scholar and the
crack slinger united by a common love of
the street
but then inevitably tragedy struck cory
booker learned that t-bone was on the
lamb from the law
by this point cory booker was the mayor
of newark so the friendship couldn't
last as booker later recalled with
sadness quote that rift between me and
t-bone was inches we sat there but i
felt so alienated that there was a gulf
as wide as the grand canyon between us
and i could not reach out to save this
young man we drove back to a housing
project called brick towers
and i've never seen him again since that
day
it's a poignant story but cory booker
isn't alone no one has seen t-bone since
that day in fact no one has ever seen
t-bone at any point ever because t-bone
doesn't exist as we later learned t-bone
is a fictional character cory booker
made him up entirely
but cory booker didn't stop there he
also invented his own identity it turns
out that cory booker is not a product of
the streets of newark not even close he
is in fact a blue-eyed rich kid from an
all-white suburb his parents were ibm
executives
now you can judge but you have to
concede that whatever else he is cory
booker is a remarkable actor he is the
jesse smallett of democratic politics a
fraud yes but a deeply committed one a
man who has honed his skills and those
skills have been on full display this
week as booker has emoted all over
contangi jackson
now jackson is an oppressed member of
the professional class too she went to
harvard and harvard law school so the
two of them have a lot in common
watch their solidarity
your family and you speak to service
service service
and i'm telling you right now i'm not
letting anybody in the senate steal my
joy
i told you this at the beginning
i i have i i'm embarrassed it happened
earlier today i just look at you and i i
start getting full of emotion you didn't
get here because of some dark money
groups
you got here how every black woman in
america who's gotten anywhere
has done
by being
like ginger roger said
i did everything fred astaire did but
backwards in heels they're gonna accuse
you of this and that heck in honor of
your
person who shares your birthday you
might be called the communist
but don't worry
my sister
don't worry
god has got you
do we make that up
do we create that and so i know that
actually happened in the united states
surface service service
that's what we call hard edge striving
now it's service
but the best was at the end don't worry
my sister
wait a second they're related
well apparently they are at least in
some hard to define spiritual sense they
have definitely seen each other at whole
foods or on the flight to edgartown for
decades these two pioneers have followed
virtually identical paths both grew up
in white-collar families both went to
multiple elite schools neither one has
ever left the tiny world of credential
mongering npr listeners who run this
country
now it's been a struggle for both of
them
but they've made it
at this point they're just sick and
tired of being sick and tired cory
booker chokes up thinking about the
journey watch
i was in the white house with my
democratic colleagues and i'm again i'm
in my joy i can't help it
and and and the president's asking her
advice who should we nominate him
whatever
and
i look at kamala and we have a knowing
glance which we've had for years when
she and i used to sit on this end of
this committee at times
and then i try to get out to the
president what it means
what it means
and i want to tell you when i look at
you this is why i get emotional
it's hard for me not to look at you and
not see my mom
not to see my
my cousins one of them who had to come
here and sit behind you she had to be
she had to have your back
i see my ancestors and yours
nobody's going to steal the joy of that
woman in the street or the calls that
i'm getting or the texts nobody's going
to steal that joy
you have earned this spot you are worthy
today you're my star
you are my harbinger of hope
that's not jesse small at did you see
the footage from the sentencing that's
not jesse's mod it's exactly jesse smell
it now you could say
i'm offended by it
but you can also acknowledge that's art
the best part cory booker and kamala
harris share a knowing glance as they
have for years
it's the mutual recognition of the
totally fraudulent a faker knows a faker
oh you're pretending to be someone
you're not me too
it's easy to enjoy all this imagine if
you worked at say cnn or msnbc
or nbc news
and you had to pretend that that was an
authentic scene
that meant something that was rooted in
some observable physical reality that
people who went to
ivy league schools
somehow are oppressed
huh
so you wouldn't want to acknowledge any
of that you would want to point out that
rather than ask a single actual question
during the confirmation hearings cory
booker just slobbered all over the
nominee
you wouldn't be able to say any of that
so you'd have to figure out a way to
ignore it and i mean our media dutifully
did watch
cory booker had no questions really he
just offered an extraordinary
extemporaneous set of remarks that
moment has kind of ruled the day after
what was really republicans hijacking so
much of this hearing what we saw senator
padilla and senator booker do to affirm
her is something that is deeply touching
in a way because we know how deeply
disrespected black women can be it's
bringing tears to my eyes right now
brought tears to my eyes yesterday
you know
what senator booker said was the god's
honest truth there are a lot of black
women who who watched cory booker and
said this is someone who came to really
give her the sort of flowers that she
deserved
you should know that not one of the
people you just saw is a poor person not
one of them is oppressed not one of them
has anything at all in common with the
people they claim to speak for so they
are to a person every bit as fraudulent
as the people on stage
telling you from the peak of the fake
meritocracy that they're somehow
fighting against the current
is of course the opposite is true
but you know how to say it but imagine
the reserve of energy it takes as a news
man to pretend having shown the clips
that we just did that that was anything
but horrifying anything but so fake that
the hair on the back your neck goes up
at the fraudulence that's honestly like
telling you that
leah thomas
is a deeply accomplished female swimmer
who's winning because she just practiced
harder than the other girls
a lot of the black women who watched
that loved it said one nbc journalist
person who can't define what a woman is
the problem with all this is easy to
make fun of but the problem is they are
praising a sitting united states senator
remember the judiciary committee for
asking zero questions during a
confirmation hearing during which we're
choosing the next supreme court justice
they're saying it is immoral because the
way that she looks to ask her real
questions to know what we're getting
before she takes the seat for life
of course this is the whole point it's
the greta thunberg play you throw
someone up there who represents your
views who can't be questioned because
anyone who questions the person is of
course mean or racist or sexist or
whatever you know pick your attack but
the person is immune from sincere
questions
that's worth telling and yet somehow it
gets even more nauseating the washington
post editorial board saw that groveling
and decided it didn't go far enough so
they published this headline yesterday
quote republicans boast they have not
pulled a kavanaugh in fact they've
treated jackson worse
so if you read the post piece and you
shouldn't obviously jeff bezos says
newspaper is utter garbage you will find
that the post editorial board is aghast
the republicans ask contangi jackson
about kitty porn about the sentences she
handed down sentences that fell far
beneath federal sentencing guidelines
contingent's explanation for her low
sentences with the guidelines are
written before the internet now that
people can amass huge amounts of kitty
porn the guidelines are too strict that
was honestly her explanation or maybe
you agree with it maybe you don't tell
us the legal principle behind that if
you would judge
again even if you agree
that because the internet makes
acquiring kiddie porn easier we
shouldn't be as tough on kiddie porn if
you think that's a fair standard
it's certainly fair to ask about it no
in a supreme court hearing
for comparison's sake and we didn't want
to go here it's just too obvious but we
can't control ourselves this is how the
emotive weepy corey booker treated the
last nominee to the supreme court
someone whose politics he doesn't agree
with he told us at the time that brett
kavanaugh was so odious
so morally filthy so satanic that anyone
who could vote for his nomination was
guilty of a mortal sin watch
in a moral moment
there is no bystanders
you are either complicit in the evil you
are either contributing to the wrong or
you are fighting against it
and the fake priestess and the fake
clerical color nods it's just so funny
if you were to take a survey of the
people most likely to give you a moral
lecture about your own moral
shortcomings they would be the people
whose personal lives could withstand the
lightest scrutiny if you know what we
mean
that is a very consistent standard
anyway
no one has used language like that to
describe opponents of contangi jackson
even though she let to restate
industrial-scale pedophiles out of jail
with three-month jail sentences nor has
anyone subjected her to questions about
her high school drinking habits remember
that hate to bring it up but here's what
it looked like
judge kavanaugh um you drank on weekdays
as well in high school not just weekends
weekdays yes sir
uh
i'd say that's
rare are you talking about during the
school year i'm talking about the
calendars that you provided during these
dates
that's in the in the summer after a
football workout when we went over that
you drank on weekdays yes or no sir
uh in the summer
when we went over to
timmy's house on july 1st that would
indicate yes yes in other words that
that july first reference to skis went
over for skis that's brewski's correct
and after tobin sir sir i just need a
yes or no that brewski's right
it's that's the guy lecturing you about
god
and like all phony people you see a
little glint of cruelty and meanness
beneath did you have a beer answer the
question
and what's funny is that brett kavanaugh
actually had to answer the question not
that it mattered in the end it wouldn't
matter what he said contingent brown
jackson meanwhile still does not explain
what the meaning of the word woman is
are women even real
turns out that question is now above the
pay grade of the us supreme court
maybe we're meant to think of women as
an archetype a pastiche
maybe they're like t-bone the baddest
drug lord in newark one minute women are
here fully female and authentic filling
you in the gritty details of womanhood
the next thing you know you drop them
off at a housing project and they're
gone forever hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else